-Good evening. I'm Seth Meyers
This is "Late Night,"
and we hope you're
doing well tonight.
Let's get to the news.
According to a new book
about the 2020 election,
Trump campaign aides
intentionally gave Rudy Giuliani
the wrong time
to show up for a debate prep
though that hardly
seems necessary.
"Hey, boss, I'm here at the bait
shop. Where are you guys?"
Amazon founder Jeff Bezos
traveled to space today
aboard his company Blue Origin's
first manned rocket launch
I'm not sure what they use
to fuel the rocket,
but based on the design,
I'm going to say
two D batteries?
President Biden will trave
tomorrow to Cincinnati, Ohio
which is about as impressive
as what Bezos did today.
That wasn't space, dude!
In a recent interview for
a new book about his presidency,
former President Trump sai
if George Washington
came back from the dead
and picked Abraham Lincoln
as his running mate,
it would be hard
for Washington and Lincoln
to beat him in an election
though I'm not sure
"I would maybe
have beaten two zombies"
is the flex he thinks it is.
According to the latest numbers,
coronavirus cases are increasing
in every state.
But, hey, if I wanted a case
of Corona, it'd be this one.
That's right.
If you're going to insist
on not getting vaccinated
and prolonging the pandemic,
we're starting jokes over
from the beginning.
We're just going to cycle back
to the 2019 punch lines.
It'll be like Groundhog Day.
You won't even be able to tell
if it's a rerun or not.
Okay?
According the latest numbers
coronavirus cases are increasing
in every state.
Wow. The only thing
more dangerous than COVID
is Carole Baskin. I'm serious.
[ Laughter ]
That was your warning.
A 20-acre mountain
in Switzerland
is up for sale on eBay
for $235,000,
but they really hammer you
on the shipping.
Major League Baseball
has reportedly banned
a New York Yankees fan for lif
from every MLB ballpark
after he threw a ball
from the stands on Saturda
at a Boston Red Sox outfielder
Said the Yankees,
"Does he have a curve ball?"
Fox News host Sean Hannity tol
viewers on his show last night
to take the coronavirus
seriously.
July 2021, right on time.
It's like if today I asked
if anyone's heard of Lizzo
Check her out.
A banner plane made
an emergency landing yesterday
on a bridge in New Jersey.
Luckily, bystanders
on the ground were prepared.
And finally,
today was World Jump Day.
And you'll probably
still get higher
than Jeff Bezos went this
morning.
That wasn't space, dude!
And that was a monologue.
Scollins coming after
Bezos hard.